frosted tips are you guys great alrighty
also today I am breaking down 2006
fashion trends because why wouldn't I'm
so fashionable so right chunky
highlights I actually excel them my
whole first photo shoots for my thankful
album I put a whole of the photo
showcase I never put any time to make my
hair net it looks so bad and I walked
and I was like how much chunky
highlights and red and black at the time
I was like I'm so edgy cool quiet
horrible idea
later on looking back but I love some
highlights ow I don't care but um keep
in whatever dudes and saggy pants it's a
little odd well first of all here's the
thing it's dudes with saggy pants that
still wear belts they're pastor by like
I don't understand like why even have
the Bell you're obviously not concerned
about keeping them up your butt showing
so pants under dresses I mean I think
this started to become a thing because
dresses started to become so much if I'd
like they'd be so short that all the
sudden I'd be like wow this is a tall
I think I was probably an accident at
first if I thought it was a top put some
jeans with it and then people are like
that's cool not cool it's not sometimes
I have to wear pants with a dress
because we we did think it was the top
and if you are mm maybe you have a big
butt like me sometimes dresses become
shirts that's what it is
and you handle it what's the black Spanx
advance Omid your tops I was into the
midriff top I'm actually really proud of
myself for being the major top because
there would be no point from here on out
that I wear a midship top so it's like
that's when you're supposed to give it
in your 20s you know before children and
you know everything started to break
down with your body
and you know it was just a good time I
loved just feeling like I was almost in
a bathing suit top it was comfortable I
wasn't trying to impress anybody I was
hot physically I just say hugs with
skirts it's a little confusing is it hot
or is it cold no one knows because
you've got a miniskirt on but then
you're wearing your uggs that are I mean
just to keep you pretty warm I don't
really get that I don't know that I did
that I probably did like a skirt with
like you know appropriate shoes like
flip-flops or like a sandal still going
out top a party top if you will
did I wear these yes I did were they
fashionable not so much but that's
anything I basically a wore it wasn't
really cool but I did actually wear some
halters because I was on tour a lot so I
always wore you know open up the back
you know sweaty that's how it is when
you look back at photos and you regret
everything chandelier earrings here's my
famous chandelier earrings not all of us
have long necks I am I don't know I feel
like it's appropriate on five three and
a half I feel like I'm proportionate but
I can't wear like sometimes my sons will
put areas I mean I can't even turn my
head I've got in a trouble on Jimmy
Fallon for this like I think they hit
and they don't hit other people like
I'll be sitting next to a chick she's
got some chandelier earrings on this is
still now this is not just to thousands
like this is 2019 as well like well
that's still 2000s but you know what I
mean the previous decade what I've heard
I can see pretty anyway I can't do
chandelier earrings I never could I
might have a short neck I don't know
silver eyeshadow no I don't care who
it's on you have to blend
that with something else and never LT
look like Mimi from The Drew Carey Show
if you remember her pretty great
a velour sweat suit so here's the thing
owned a few I did here's the thing on
one now cuz it like came back it's like
all this I never he's wearing athleisure
and track suits and I'm all about it
except I don't really look like you know
like bottles we're like one of those
things that it's like oh my god so hot
so cool I don't look like that I look
you know like a mom before it's just
[ __ ] my buggy at Target vandeyn is a
shirt totally - this yeah I did all
forms of like the triangle with the
midriff I like the mid Jim I'm so glad
to I wore that out cuz that tight little
tummy is a it's a memory I love my
children corset tops here's the best
thing I feel like in early 2000 people
wore corset tops with pants and then
later on just of course it and like just
some underwear I feel like fashion is
going away because people aren't wearing
clothes anymore but it's fun frosted
tips
oh you guys it's great it's like men
that you know especially straight guys
that really wanted to be cool and hip
and go in and get like you know gay guys
always got it right somehow it like
looked good but I'm feeling some
straight guys don't always really mess
that up and then overuse of Flatiron
yeah a soul patch that's it's gross it's
awesome
Canadian tuxedos well here's the thing I
work on the voice and Blake wears one
every day allianz is denim and so plaid
doesn't think that went out of style for
stuff I think they're still holding on
somebody's gotta get the boy in like a
real soon
it's gotta happen come on in capri pants
perform denim love them not against them
now actually names an entire company
after I call them pants they're not
pants not short so confusing which bands
one of my companies that's right I'm
Clifford of all the trends I've seen I
bring every one of them back because I
have no sense of stuff I mean I just
don't care if I wear jeans and t-shirts
every day and I'm okay with it it's not
my vibe I do like a good jacket but my
focus is books and bags
I'm totally my mom I can't say no to a
bag you know why it fits every time I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this